hey guys it's justine and today we have
the brand new microsoft surface duo so
this is just gonna be an unboxing and a
first look at it and then we will have a
full review after i've had some time to
spend with it and test it out but today
it is here
i feel like when i opened this that
there should have been some music
playing there should have been lights
it looks like a cake box maybe there's
not a surface duo maybe there's cake in
here okay i don't think there's cake
so this is the press kit they sent this
out to a bunch of reviewers
and journalists for us to get a chance
to show it to you guys
there it is oh wow wow we've also got
some microsoft surface earbuds
and the duo here it is it's in this box
it's inside this is real
so this is cool because this device is
kind of reinventing the way that
you're using devices and they've been
very adamant about the way that these
two displays
work together so you really can have two
separate experiences happening at the
same time
so this is the 256 gig version there are
two different versions there's one that
is a 128 so that will allow you decide
which size
storage you would like this has six gigs
of ram with a qualcomm snapdragon
processor
so let's open it up and get that first
look
oh man this looks so cool this looks so
i'm so excited you guys i'm
freaking freaking out this is a first
touch
this is a first hold this is the first
feel of the microsoft surface duo
it feels nice one of the things that i
think i was worried about with this is
it was gonna feel
sort of plasticky so it's not gonna have
like a substantial feel to it
oh it's so shiny look at this look at
this look at this
[Music]
that was satisfying this the open
the opening is incredibly satisfying
so smooth so during the press conference
they kept calling the different ways
that you hold this
a pose so there's various poses that you
guys saw at the beginning of this video
on the box
so let's go through those right now book
mode please
compose mode single screen mode
i think this is my personal favorite
[Music]
tent mode i don't know how they came up
with that name
i mean they really really outdid
themselves with that one
and then last but not least there's peak
mode so you just can kind of like take a
little look inside
peak mode peak like you're taking a peek
let's take a look and see what else is
in the box and then we'll talk more
about the device
oh surface duo bumper specifically
designed to protect your device
we all know i'm gonna need this this
kind of reminds me of
like when you would go bowling when you
were younger and they would put bumpers
on the bowling alley so that you would
always
get some pins i mean maybe it was just
me i thought i was
a champion i think i can figure this out
without watching the tutorial video
i'm not sure i think we're gonna go
bumper-less
but that's just me oh surprise
usb-c cable this looks to be
our sim card ejector probably
instructions
this is probably the charging brick
surprise
it's almost like i'm a mind reader that
is the best
looking tool screen time do you want to
touch it what do you want yeah
guys tyler sold i wanted like it's
honestly like just
it's really cool i know oh my
it's like they're not they're not trying
to be like hey
we're one big screen it's like dual
monitors but
but a baby size shoe
it's so cool we all know
that i might or might not be a little
dramatic sometimes
when i'm unboxing things i've been
trying to tone it down but i'm really
struggling to keep my excitement under
wraps because
this just looks really good
like the feel of it i haven't even
turned the thing on yet
so it is powered by usbc and over here
is where you'd be putting your sim card
let's give you a nice look
we've got our power button and the
volume so this does only have one camera
it is a six megapixel camera
but with this this could be a
front-facing camera
or a back-facing camera
i know i'm pretty sure that this is not
going to be the best camera that is on a
smartphone right now there are so many
phones out that have
such high-end cameras it is six
megapixels i haven't tried it out yet so
i can't say what the photos look like
but of course you better believe that we
will be doing a video and photo test and
here's the hinge mechanism during the
press event they were showing all of the
technology and the research that they
did
to make this as effective as possible i
think the samsung galaxy z flip was
rated for 200 000 folds whereas this is
just it's a hinge you're not folding the
actual class device itself
i don't even think that this is
something that is in the same category
as those foldable devices
because yes this is fold but there are
two different screens
and the reason that this is so special
is because they're making these two
screens
kind of like dual monitors so just
picture yourself if you're working on
your computer and you have dual monitors
this gives you a lot more screen real
estate to be able to do things
so you're able to open android apps
microsoft 365 apps
and they will all work on this device
which is kind of crazy if you think
about it like microsoft and android
teaming up getting together saying
what's up
let's make a cool device and let's make
this happen pretty cool so i wanted to
do a size comparison to
the iphone 11 pro max so this is the
bigger iphone but i wanted you guys to
be able to see if you know what size
this phone is
to kind of give you a reference point of
the size of this device
and then if we put it right on top of it
a little bit thinner
the actual thinness of the device is
almost about the same as the iphone
so here's the thinness and compared to
one of the sides
so there's one side compared to the
thickness of the iphone
i mean we can make a sandwich definitely
wouldn't recommend doing that
but if you wanted to you could so here
it is in comparison to the iphone
when it's all unfolded and as far as
weight
a very bad judgment but they feel about
the same
this is a scientific weight measurement
right now so they're not calling this
device a phone
i'm not really sure what i would call it
because it's not really a tablet
it is sort of in its own new category
thank you guys so much for watching i
look forward to doing a full review and
test of this if there's anything that
you guys would like us to test out leave
it in the comments below if you have any
questions we will try to address those
and test them in the next video don't
forget to subscribe
and hit the bell so you'll be notified
when i post this video and any other new
ones
with that i will see you guys later
bye i'm gonna go i'm gonna go finally
turn this on now but you guys can't see
it yet
it's gone it's gone it's gone tyler you
can't take that because look what this
says
this says that we are one of the first
devices one of the first 50. oh my god
we gotta go find the other 49. do you
think we should all meet up we have a
covered meet up
isn't it nice it's seriously
it's the i feel like it's the only like
good
new thing like since like you know ipad
[Music]